[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui l'accord sur le
nucléaire iranien
après le retrait américain et le
désengagement partiel de l'iran cet
accord n'a quasiment plus corps et se
retrouve presque dépourvue de sens quels
sont les derniers développements liés au
dossier nucléaire iranien qui fait
l'objet d'âpres batailles diplomatiques
à l'international le 4 juillet 2020 les
signataires européens du traité sur le
nucléaire iranien
réitère une fois de plus leur
attachement odile et appelle à le sauver
pourtant son avenir est très incertain
début janvier 2020 l'iran annonce ne
plus suivre les limites imposées sur son
programme nucléaire
en réponse la france l'allemagne et le
royaume-uni déclenché une procédure
juridique contre téhéran
un acte qui provoque une vive réaction
de la république islamique qui est
déclenché à son tour une contre
procédure visant la france l'allemagne
le royaume uni et les etats unis
téhéran les accuse de multiples
violations de leurs obligations
découlant du traité
de son côté washington avance l'idée de
conclure un nouvel accord sur le
nucléaire iranien
idée qui ne trouvent pas de soutien
parmi les signataires restantes du deal
la russie et la chine s'opposent en
outre à l'initiative américaine suggéré
à l'onu de prolonger l'embargo
international sur les ventes d'armes à
l'iran qui expire partiellement en
octobre 2020
[Musique]
mais avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il
faut savoir sur les sens de l'accord sur
le nucléaire iranien
c'est le blitz longue d'une centaine de
pages le traité est signée le 14 juillet
2015 à vienne entre l'iran et le p5 + 1
les cinq membres du conseil de sécurité
des nations unies plus l'allemagne sont
contenues repose sur trois piliers
principaux une limitation du programme
nucléaire iranien un régime renforcé
d'inspections et levée des sanctions
internationales contre l'iran
conformément au texte du traité les ans
s'engage à ne pas enrichir l'uranium à
plus de 3 67% ce qui exclut toute
possibilité de produire des armes
nucléaires
le nombre de centrifugeuses doit passer
de 19 mille à cinq mille soixante
elles seront toutes installées au coeur
d'un seul site nucléaire à natanz
pourtant là aussi la quantité d'uranium
enrichi ne doit pas dépasser 300 kg et
celle d'eau lourde
130 tonnes la surveillance et le
contrôle régulier des sites nucléaires
iraniens sont confiées à l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique qui
reste toujours sur place en échange les
sanctions adoptées par l'union
européenne et les etats unis visant les
secteurs de la finance de l'énergie et
du transport iraniens doivent être levés
le nude annuler elle aussi plusieurs de
ses résolutions adoptées contre l'iran
depuis 2006 pourtant les embargos sur
les armes conventionnelles et sur les
missiles balistiques resteront en
vigueur jusqu'en 2020 et 2023
respectivement l'accord sur le nucléaire
iranien ne tient plus qu'à un fil
en cause le retrait américain suivi d'un
désengagement progressif de léran cette
évolution inquiète les signataires
européen qui déclenche une procédure
juridique contre l'iran la république
islamique répond par le lancement d'une
contre procédures accusant les européens
et les états unis de multiples
violations de l'accord pourtant sauver
cet accord est toujours possible
pour cela les iraniens pose deux
exigences soit l'octroi davantage
économique par l'union européenne qui
permettrait d'atténuer les effets
négatifs des sanctions américaines soit
le retour des etats unis dans le traité
mais pour l'instant ni l'un ni l'autre
ne sont à l'ordre du jour car washington
ne veut même pas entendre parler du
retour dans ce traité pour donald trump
le texte actuel est tout simplement
défaillante
il veut donc négocier un nouvel accord
qui restreindrait encore plus le
programme nucléaire de téhéran
et avec lui certains aspects de la
politique iranienne initiative à
laquelle les signataires restant de
l'accord restent plutôt sceptique
néanmoins washington continue à exercer
une politique de pression maximale sur
téhéran
en plus des sanctions économiques déjà
adopté l'administration de trump propose
à l'onu de prolonger l'embargo
international sur les armes qui expire
partiellement en octobre 2020 pourtant
moscou et pékin se prononcent contre
alors pourquoi l'administration de
donald trump insiste-t-elle absolument
sur un nouvel accord
comment le nu réagit-elle à la
suspension du respect des engagements
côté iranien
quelles sont les solutions envisagées
pour sauver cet accord pour répondre à
ces questions nous rejoignons david
rigaud les roses chercheurs à l'ifas et
chercheur associé à l'iris rédacteur en
chef de la revue orient stratégique
monsieur rigoler rose bonjour jours tout
d'abord à quoi sert le désengagement
iranien de l'accord nucléaire en passant
outre les limitations posées par
l'accord que l'iran veut t-il réalisé au
juste lyon répondait à simplement à la
sortie unilatérale jeu tu parles que six
d'entre eux le 8 mai 2010huit président
travail considéré que l'accord qui a été
signé à n'était pas suffisamment
contraignant donc de manière unilatérale
et les états unis n'en faisait plus
partie à la suite de quoi après une
période de latence le téhéran avait cité
de répondre envoyer des messages en se
signalant tous les deux mois à partir du
8 mai 2010 neuf sous sa rétractation par
rapport aux différents engagements qui
étaient effectivement impliqué par
l'accord signé dans le gie si tu dois
donc l'accord nucléaire iranien de 2015
ça c'est fait pareil
la première demie mais d'abord
concernant le sperme d'enrichissement
puis le plafond d'enrichissement à 3 67%
augmenté ensuite la question des
centrifugeuses notamment la cuisine de
latence et à la suite objectivement de
ses diverses étapes
aujourd'hui le liant et qu'à ce moment
c'est quasiment un affranchi de
l'essentiel des contraintes qui lui a
été imposée par l'accord c'était un
message destiné effectivement aux
signataires pour les mettre au pied du
mur
donc cet accord soit respectée aussi où
donc les motivations de donald trump
on les verra un peu plus tard dans cette
émission mais aujourd'hui le président
américain veut conclure un nouvel accord
parmi ces exigences est mentionné
notamment le statut permanent pour
toutes les restrictions sur les rangs
car aujourd'hui ils ont une durée
limitée dans le temps
pensez vous que les dispositions de
l'accord actuel soit vraiment
insuffisante alors elles ont été jugées
insuffisantes par le lin trump et pas
par les signataires au moment où
l'accord a été effectivement le valider
il ya effectivement parfois des zones
d'ombré c'est à dire la question de la
pérennité des clauses contraignantes a
été évoqué à plusieurs reprises par
uniquement par donald trump d'ailleurs
il ya un an par le président macro
c'était sa fameuse théorie des quatre
piliers et l'iran maintient l'accord ne
pas le remettre en cause complète
notamment sur la question des délais
prolongés la question du balistiques et
l'engagement régional de liens mais en
tout état de cause pour l'instant on
n'en est pas le moment d loin simplement
le président donald trump considère que
cette question de la pérennisation des
empreintes étaient était une quelque
chose qui n'était pas acceptable de son
point de vue et ces cinq là dessus c'est
ce qui a justifié son retrait le
problème c'est que le retrait américain
combat de l'accord tel qu'il avait été
signé en 2015
merci beaucoup monsieur rigoler rose
nous allons poursuivre notre analyse
tout de suite mais nous vous
retrouverons en fin d'émission pour plus
de détails sur la question merci
le 4 juillet 2020 les signataires
européen de l'accord sur le nucléaire
iranien la france le royaume uni et
l'allemagne et réaffirme une fois de
plus leur attachement à ce deal avec la
france et la grande bretagne ne
confirmons que nous restons pleinement
déterminé à maintenir l'accord de vienne
nous la troïka européenne sans exception
avons rempli nos obligations au titre de
jc perreault a notamment en ce qui
concerne la levée des sanctions
les appelle à sauver l'accord viennent
aussi d'autres participants du deal à
savoir la russie et la chine pourtant
aujourd'hui le sort du traité reste très
incertain car un an après le retrait des
etats-unis l'iran commencent à réduire
graduellement ses engagements en matière
nucléaire et aujourd'hui il ne suit plus
aucune limitation imposée par le traité
tout d'abord la quantité d'uranium
faiblement enrichi le traité interdit
aller en d'en posséder plus de 300 kg or
selon le dernier rapport de l'aïe à la
république islamique en dispose
actuellement de 1571 ensuite les stocks
d'eau lourde
l'iran en a 2 tonne et demi de plus
qu'il est autorisé
le taux d'enrichissement d'uranium n'est
pas respectée non plus alors que le
maximum imposées par le traité de 3 67%
ce taux en iran s'élève aujourd'hui à
4,5 pour son de plus les rangs rouge est
toute limitation imposée sur ses
activités de recherche et développement
liées au programme nucléaire
à cela s'ajoute également la reprise des
activités d'enrichissement sur le site
de fordo interdite par l'accord enfin le
5 janvier 2020 l'iran rompt avec la
dernière limitations imposées par le
traité
celle du nombre de centrifugeuses un
acte symbolique fort qui provoque une
vive réaction des autres partis
signataires
mais si la russie et la chine se limite
aux appels au maintien de l'accord la
france l'allemagne et le royaume uni
vont plus loin
le 14 janvier 2020 il déclenché le
mécanisme de règlement des différends
prévues par le texte du traité alors que
prévoit-il premièrement que les parties
signataires tente de trouver un
compromis à travers des consultations
approfondies
celle ci se déroule d'abord au niveau
des hauts fonctionnaires puis au niveau
des ministres des affaires étrangères la
durée de cette période n'est pas
déterminé si aucune solution ne devait
être trouvée le différend pourrait être
porté devant le conseil de sécurité
hélas les rangs risquerait le retour des
sanctions internationales
aujourd'hui ce mécanisme reste au point
mort la seule rencontre à avoir eu lieu
dans le cadre de la procédure s'est
déroulée fin février à vienne et n'a pas
abouti à de grandes avancées
pourtant les états européens entendent
pas reculer ils exigent une nouvelle
réunion ministérielle afin de faire
avancer le processus
à son tour l'iran ne reste pas les bras
croisés déclenché début juillet une
nouvelle procédure de règlement des
différends et cette fois ci contre la
troïka européenne et les etats unis
téhéran les accuse de multiples
violations de leurs obligations dans le
cadre de l'accord il s'agit entre autres
du retrait américain ou des sanctions
économiques réimposer sûreté ans
pourquoi ce processus maintenant et bien
la goutte qui a fait déborder le vase
était une résolution soumise à l'aiea
par la troïka européenne en juin 2020
le document exhorte l'iran à coopérer
avec l'aiea qui demande un vin l'accès à
deux sites soupçonnée d'avoir abrité
dans le passé des activités nucléaires
non déclarées le 19 juin
la résolution est adoptée par le conseil
des gouverneurs de l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique
ce qui provoque évidemment la colère de
terre malgré ce ton offensif téhéran ne
ferme pas la porte au dialogue
l'iran se dit prêt à revenir à
l'application pleine et entière de ses
engagements
mais pour cela la république islamique
exige qu'au moins une des deux
conditions soient remplies
la première serait le retour des etats
unis dans le traité en pratique il
s'agirait là d'un échange la levée des
sanctions contre l'application stricte
des limites fixées par l'accord pourtant
même si washington devait refuser
l'accord pourrait toujours être sauvé
cela l'iran exige un nombre d' avantages
économiques de la part de l'union
européenne qui permettrait à téhéran
d'atténuer les lourdes conséquences des
sanctions américaines
mais pour washington il est hors de
question de revenir dans le traité la
levée des sanctions n'est pas envisagé
non plus la tendance est aujourd'hui
plutôt inverse au gré des mois
l'administration de trump renforce étape
par étape la pression économique sur
téhéran et la liste des restrictions ne
fait que s'allonger
à ce jour elles s'étendent sur tous les
secteurs clés de l'économie iranienne
secteur aéronautique électronique
chimiques automobiles énergétique et
financier toute entreprise commerçants
avec les airs en violation des sanctions
pourraient se voir refuser l'accès au
marché américain sur la liste noire
américaine figure aussi un nombre de
hauts responsables iraniens
parmi eux le guide suprême iranien
l'ayatollah ali khamenei et le chef de
la diplomatie iranienne mohammad zareen
tous leurs actifs étrangers et ceux de
leurs proches doivent être gelée de son
côté l'iran n'hésite pas non plus à
hausser le ton à l'encontre de
washington même si ses actions
rv est parfois un caractère plutôt
symbolique le 29 juin téhéran annonce
via son agence de presse officielle
avoir émis un mandat d'arrêt contre le
président des états unis
il est inculpé pour le meurtre de qassem
soleimani l'un des principaux chefs
militaires du pays
les autorités iraniennes ont même
sollicité l'aide d'interpol sur ce
dossier pourtant la réponse est
prévisible lagence considère la demande
comme politisé et refuse de la traiter à
washington cette nouvelle est passée
inaperçue
or ce qui inquiète vraiment les
autorités américaines c'est la mise en
place du mécanisme un steak ce sens et
contourner les restrictions américaines
dans le commerce entre l'union
européenne et l'iran voici son mode de
fonctionnement afin d'éviter les
transactions en dollars
les entreprises européennes et iranienne
se prépare à faire du troc par exemple
un exportateur iranien qui vend des
tapis en europe seraient payés non pas
par la société européenne directement
mais par un importateur iranien qui doit
acheter en europe
disons des médicaments la transaction
resterait donc à l'intérieur du pays
sans utiliser de monnaies étrangères
car en europe la société qui a fabriqué
les médicaments seraient payés par celle
qui a débloqué les fonds pour les tapis
la boucle serait donc bouclée dans un
premier temps l'insecte n'assurerait que
le commerce des produits non couverts
par des sanctions américaines à savoir
les dispositifs médicaux les produits
pharmaceutiques et agroalimentaires
alors ce fameux mécanisme un steak ce
sera t-il suffisant pour alléger les
conséquences lourdes des sanctions
américaines qui pèsent sur les rangs
quelles conditions les etats unis
avancent utile pour lever leur embargo
économique
la réponse après la pause
[Musique]
près de cinq ans après sa signature
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien et sur
le point de tomber à l'eau mais l'espoir
n'est toujours pas perdu pour sauver ce
traité aujourd'hui tant critiquée par
washington
pourtant les américains honteux même
joué un rôle dans le lancement du
programme nucléaire iranien
c'était la fin des années 50 que l'iran
lance son programme nucléaire uniquement
à des fins civiles
en 1957 l'iran adhère au programme atom
pour la paix lancée par les états unis
qui promet une utilisation pacifique de
l'énergie nucléaire
aux termes de cet accord les états unis
convient de fournir un réacteur de
recherche de 5 mégawatts thermiques et
de centrales électriques
l'année suivante et errants rejoint
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
atomique où a lieu à en 1968 elle si le
traité de non prolifération nucléaire et
accepte donc de ne pas se doter de
l'arme nucléaire mais elle dispose tout
de même du droit de développer une
énergie nucléaire civile
depuis lors le pays entreprend une
étroite collaboration avec les pays
occidentaux
en 1975 l'allemagne est de l'iran à la
construction de sa première centrale
nucléaire à bouchehr
deux ans plus tard la france entame la
construction d'un second site dans le
pays
cependant la fin des années soixante dix
marque un véritable tournant dans le
dossier nucléaire iranien après la
révolution islamique de 1979 le pays
devient une république islamique avec à
sa tête l'ayatollah khomeini dès sa
prise de pouvoir khomeiny se distancier
des puissances européennes et j'ai le
programme jugeant l'utilisation de cette
énergie contraires aux principes de
l'islam
pourtant il revient sur sa position la
suite de la guerre iran irak qui débute
en 1981 l'irak de saddam hussein
utilisent des armes chimiques l'iran
souhaite alors renforcer sa sécurité et
le développement du secteur nucléaire
devient de nouveau une priorité pour
l'iran
face au refus des pays occidentaux de
poursuivre toute coopération nucléaire
l'iran se tourner dès les années 90
alors vers l'argentine la russie puis la
chine qui le fournissent en uranium et
en technologie et ce dans un but
pacifique à la suite des attentats du 11
septembre 2001 le président george w
bush accuse l'iran de faire partie de l'
axe du mal c'est à dire de soutenir le
terrorisme
la prolifération d'armes de destruction
massive c'est à ce moment que les états
unis commencent à se préoccuper de plus
en plus du programme nucléaire de leur
nouveau rival stratégique l'europe
commence aussi à se soucier des
activités nucléaires iraniennes
en 2003 la france l'allemagne et le
royaume-uni 10 us roi entame des
négociations avec l'iran
elles aboutiront à la déclaration de
téhéran qui prévoit des inspections
inopinées de l'iea sur les sites
nucléaires
l'année suivante sous la pression de
l'ue octroie l'iran suspende
l'enrichissement en uranium
cependant l'arrivée au pouvoir du
président conservateur mahmoud
ahmadinejad en 2005 change la donne il
décide de reprendre l'enrichissement de
l'uranium et insiste sur le fait que
l'iran souhaite développer le nucléaire
civil est pas la bombe sans pour autant
convaincre les pays occidentaux en
réponse le conseil de sécurité de l'onu
votée en 2006 la résolution 1737
puis en 2007 la résolution 1747
elle impose un embargo contre l'iran sur
les technologies et les armes liées au
nucléaire tels que les missiles
balistiques et interdisent l'importation
et l'exportation d'uranium enrichi en
2013 nouveau changement de pouvoir le
modéré hassan rohani se vit c'est la
présidence iranienne il se distancie de
son prédécesseur il souhaite entamer de
nouvelles négociations sur le nucléaire
afin d'obtenir un allégement des
sanctions qui paralyse le pays
une décision accueillie favorablement
par les états unis en 2015 après 20 mois
de négociations les membres permanents
du conseil de sécurité et l'allemagne
p5 + 1 signé avec l'iran l'accord de
vienne sur le nucléaire iranien ou jc
perreault a
il prévoit une série de mesures limitant
le programme nucléaire iranien en
échange d'une levée progressive des
sanctions à l'échelle mondiale et
nationale contre la république islamique
néanmoins ces avancées seront de courte
durée
fraîchement élu en 2016 le président
américain donald trump veut rompre avec
le jcp hoa qu'il qualifie de désastreux
et de pire accord de tous les temps même
s'il a eu à réaffirme que l'iran ne
viole pas le jcp hoa les etats-unis se
retient officiellement de l'accord en
2018 et rétablir des sanctions au plus
haut niveau contre l'iran en effet
quelles sont les clauses de l'accord
actuel qui sont jugées inacceptables par
donald trump tout premièrement toutes
les restrictions nucléaire dans le
traité ont une durée limitée certaines
d'entre elles arrivent à expiration
téhéran pourra disposer d'autant de
centrifugeuses qu'il veut dans dix ans
au bout de quinze ans il devient
possible pour l'iran de construire de
nouvelles usines d'enrichissement
d'uranium d'en stocker plus de 300 kg et
de l'enrichir jusqu'à un niveau
militaire et dans 25 ans il n'y aura
plus d'inspections supplémentaire des
sites nucléaires iraniens
washington souhaite donc que les
restrictions de l'accord de vienne soit
permanente pour taire par ailleurs que
le nucléaire iranien reste civile ou pas
donald trump souhaiterait que téhéran
renonce à son programme balistique
selon washington de telles armes
pourraient être munis de givre nucléaire
et serait donc dangereuse pour la
sécurité de la région
enfin la maison blanche voudrait que les
rangs cesse de soutenir des groupes
militaires que les états unis qui a les
filles de terroristes parmi eux le
hezbollah qui siège au parlement
libanais ou encore le mouvement chiite
assaëb al-haq connu entre autres pour sa
participation à la libération de mossoul
de l'emprise de dèche le retrait de la
syrie et la fin de soutien aux outils au
yémen la liste de demandes est longue
des changements radicaux que washington
veut voir dans un nouvel accord plutôt
que de modifier le deal actuelle une
proposition aussitôt rejetée par un iran
outré avant de négocier il veut que
washington lève ses sanctions et
reviennent dans le cadre de l'accord
existant en effet tout en proposant des
pourparlers les etats unis continuent
d'appliquer leur stratégie de pression
maximale sur téhéran
de plus ils ont trouvé un nouveau levier
pour l'exercer
le conseil de sécurité de l'onu doit
dépendre l'embargo avant que la violence
iranienne ne dégénère et qu'une nouvelle
course aux armements ne commence au
moyen-orient le compte à rebours a
commencé
en effet selon l'accord nucléaire
l'embargo sur les armes à l'encontre de
léran expire partiellement en octobre
prochain pour l'empêcher fin juin les
etats-unis se met un projet de
résolution au conseil de sécurité de
l'onu son objectif est d'instaurer un
embargo permanent sur la vente et
l'achat des armes à l'iran à la place de
celui qui expire
pourtant avant même le vote l'initiative
paraît condamné la russie et la chine
pays ayant le droit de veto au conseil
ont déclaré leur ferme opposition à une
telle résolution
nous ne pouvons accepter les tentatives
de légitimer la politique américaine de
pression maximale sur l'iran par ce
conseil
ce que nous obtenons en fin de compte
est une escalade incontrôlable un échec
qui ne dissuade pas les diplomates
au contraire pour arriver à son but
washington avance à un nouvel argument
et affirme qu'il est toujours étape
participants de l'accord iraniens au
moins sur le papier
effectivement le retrait américain du
plan d'action global comment est
entérinée par donald trump le 8 mai 2018
depuis washington n'est donc plus sont
signataires pourtant il existe un autre
document international contraignant qui
énumère les états participants c'est la
résolution 22,31 du conseil de sécurité
instrument principal de l'onu pour
mettre en oeuvre l'accord nucléaire
adoptée en 2015 elle n'a jamais été
amendée même après le retrait américain
et désigne toujours les états unis comme
signataire de plein droit
une subtilité juridique dont washington
veut profiter pour déclencher le retour
des sanctions onusiennes sur l'iran y
compris l'embargo sur les armes un droit
dont dispose chaque membre de cet accord
aujourd'hui les sanctions contre l'iran
sont
les mais la résolution 22 31 prévoit une
procédure pour le retour voici ces
termes dans le cas où l'une des parties
signataires estiment que l'autre ne
remplit pas ses obligations
elle peut porter l affaire devant le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu suite à
quoi le conseil a un mois pour voter la
résolution sur le prolongement du régime
de la levée des sanctions
si dans les 30 jours cette résolution
n'est pas adopté les sanctions contre
l'iran entreront à nouveau en vigueur et
la washington membres permanents du
conseil pourrait évidemment jouer
pleinement de son droit de veto
la route sera donc ouverte pour les
états unis pour imposer au monde entier
leur pression sur terre pourtant
peuvent-ils vraiment utiliser une simple
faille juridique pour invoquer l'accord
dont ils se sont retirés téhéran moscou
et pékin qualifie déjà cette manoeuvre
d'illégitime une réaction prévisible
pour les adversaires américains en
revanche washington n'est pas soutenue
dans ses intentions même par ses alliés
nous sommes fermement convaincus que
toute tentative unilatérale de recourir
aux mécanismes de ce nabab des sanctions
aurait de graves conséquences au conseil
de sécurité des nations unies nous ne
soutiendrons pas une telle décision qui
serait incompatible avec nos efforts
actuels pour préserver le jcp aux as
pour mieux comprendre les perspectives
de ce fameux traité nous rejoignons à
nouveau david rigoulet roze chercheurs à
l'ifas et chercheur associé à l'iris
rédacteur en chef de la revue orient
stratégique
monsieur rigoler rose la condition de
l'iran dans cette situation est la
suivante soit washington revient dans
l'accord soit l'union européenne lui
offre un certain nombre d'avantagés
économiques pour pallier aux effets
négatifs des sanctions américaines
pourtant peut-il vraiment compter sur
ses partenaires européens aujourd'hui
non ça n'est pas le cas c'est
précisément ce que tu il stigmatise de
téhéran et c'est ce qui a justifié aussi
sa logique de désengagement par étapes
en disant que c'était réversible c'était
pas définitif mais au fil des fils des
bois t on constaté
les européens n'étaient pas en mesure
effectivement de lui offrir cette
possibilité notamment le fameux véhicule
commercial qui permettrait de contourner
les sanctions américaines
avec le monopole du dollar et les héros
bien n'ont pas été en mesure de le faire
c'est ce que c'est précisément ce que
reproche on les iraniens aujourd'hui et
donc on est là on est dans une forme
d'impasse parce que de toute façon il ya
le la pression maximale américaine d'un
côté avec la perspective de l'élection
présidentielle américaine de novembre
prochain si tu n'es pas anodin et on
peut penser que les iraniens j'irais
plutôt d'un bon oeil un autre candidat à
la maison blanche
et puis de l'autre côté évidemment le
lait qui demeure signataires en
l'occurrence les européens plus la chine
et la russie mais la question des
relations commerciales de toute façon
est hypothéquée par la logique que
j'évoquais extraterritoriale où les
sanctions américaines et donc d'une
certaine manière c'est un peu la
quadrature du cercle
c'est possible en deux mots vraiment
très brièvement pour vous cet accord
dans l'état actuel des choses at il un
avenir oui ou non
alors pour l'instant cet accord et est
en voie de désagrégation
même si les autres signataires essaie de
maintenir en vie avec toutes les
difficultés que cela comporte
c'est d'autant plus compliqué pour les
européens que les européens 1 saleen
progressivement sur une chambre
d'exigences renforcées notamment parce
que il ya les rapports de l'animal
agence internationale de l'énergie qui
atomique qui évoque un manque de
coopération et de transparence de
téhéran actuellement ce qui laisse le
spectre du tu as d'un retour potentiel
nations unies avec je souhaiterais
évidemment les américains avec le
principe du tabac c'est à dire qu'est ce
qu'une victoire mettrait le
rétablissement de toutes les sanctions
ce que ne souhaite pas les européens ni
les russes évidemment ni des chinois
mais
effectivement aujourd'hui la situation
paraît bloquée merci beaucoup
david rigoulet roze je rappelle vous
êtes chercheur à l'ifas et chercheur
associé à l'iris rédacteur en chef de la
revue orient stratégique merci d'avoir
participé à notre émission cette partie
là n'est pas encore terminée la semaine
prochaine une nouvelle partie vous
attend avec d'autres pions sur
l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]